نبقى في خانيونس حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره
باستمرار الاشتباكات في بلده القراره
والمناطق الشرقيه وهذه مشاهد وردتنا من
هناك تظهر تصاعد اعمده
الدخان من خان يونس ينضم الينا الصحفي
اسماعيل ابو عمر اسماعيل ارحب بك اذا
استهداف لمنازل في خانيونس و حصيله
الشهداء في
ارتفاع نعم بالتاكيد اداد الشهداء في
تزايد في محضه خنوس نتيجه عمليات القصف
والغارات التي تق بها غارات الاحتلال بين
الحين والاخر على اهداف ومنازل المواطنين
في المحافظه الحديث يدور ان اكثر هذه
الغارات دمويه كانت في منطقه الفخاري او
ما بين منطقه الفخاري ومنطقه حي المناره
تحديدا حيث تم استهداف
منزل مليء بالسكان ادى ذلك الاستهداف الى
ارتقاء 27 شهيد جلهم من عائله معمر هذا
الاستهداف كان بشكل مباشر لهذا المنزل
وايضا
في محيط هذا المنزل كان هناك ايضا خيام
لنازحين في محيط هذا المنزل اقاموها
وانشائها المواطنون من اجل الايواء اليها
في ظل انهم نزحوا من المناطق الشرقيه
وكذلك مناطق كانت معرضه لعمليات القصف
التي تقوم بها طائرات الاحتلال
فقام المواطنون تلك الخيام في محيط هذه
المناطق الزراعيه حتى يامن على انفسهم لكن
تعرضوا ايضا لعمليات قصف من قبل طائرات
الاحتلال وهذا الذي رفع هذا هذه الحصيله
بخصوص الشهداء 27 شهيد من عائله معمر
وهناك ثلاثه شهداء على ما يبدو من عائلات
اخرى في منطقه الحي الاوروبي في محافظه
خان يونس ايضا غارات عديده نفذت طارات
الاحتلال بالامس وفجر هذا اليوم في
المحافظه حتى هذه اللحظه لم نبلغ عن وقوع
اصابات نتيجه هذه الغارات التي نفذتها
ارات الاحتلال على مبد انها استهدفت منازل
لمواطنين في هذه المنطقه لكن هذه المنازل
على ما يبدو مخلاه من المواطنين على صعيد
الوضع الميداني خصوصا في المناطق الشرقيه
لمحافظه خيوس وكذلك الشماليه الشرقيه
للمحافظه وكذلك شمال وسط المحافظه هذه
المحاور الثلاثه التي تشهد عمليات توغل من
قبل اليات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه في تلك
المناطق هناك اشتباكات بين الحين والاخر
بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وكذلك قوات
الاحتلال واليات الاحتلال خاصه في الاجزء
الشماليه من وسط محافظه خانيونس حيث اليات
تتوغل الى الناحيه الجنوبيه من الوسط في
ساعات الليل ومع ساعات الصباح تتراجع هذه
الاليات الى اماكن تحشد وتمركزها في منطقه
شارع خمسه وكذلك باتجاه منطقه الكتيبه
اضافه الى ايضا منطقه المحطه كل هذه
التطورات مع كل تعميق من قبل اليات
الاحتلال في داخل محافظه خانيونس سيكون
هناك مواجهات ضاريه واشتباكات ضاريه مع
المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي تتصدى بكل قوه
لهذه الاليات باستخدام وسائلها القتاليه
المختلفه وتظهر ويظهر ايضا ابناء المقاومه
الفلسطينيه من اي يعني انفاق عدوها مسبقا
لمواجهه هذا العدوان الاسرائيلي وخصوصا
التقدم اليات الاحتلال في منطقه خان يونس
في هذه اللحظات في مستشفى ناصر ومستشفى
كذلك غزه الاوروبي يستعد المواطنون لتشييع
جثامين الشهداء الذين ارتقوا خلال الليل
الماضيه وفجر هذا يوم وسط حاله من الحزن
تسيطر على هؤلاء المواطنين مع فقدان عدد
كبير من ابنائهم وذويهم في مثل هذه
الغارات شكرا لك اسماعيل ابو عمر كنت معنا
من خان
يونس